hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we're going to be taking a look at
the new MacBook Pro this is the 15-inch
with the touch bar I did a live unboxing
which was the first time I've ever
unboxed anything live I'll put a link in
the description if you guys want to
watch that and also an annotation or a
card somewhere on the screen so here it
is now the first thing that a lot of
people have been talking about is the
Apple logo so in a lot of ways they went
for the same look as the MacBook Air the
air had the very metallic Apple logo
they basically completely redesigned the
keyboard but this is a this is that guys
we've got our Thunderbolt 3 but also USB
C compatible ports 2 on this side we
also have 2 on this side and we also
have our headphone jack something that I
thought was funny is they removed the
headphone jack on the iPhone which is
fine but they put one in the new MacBook
Pros but they also didn't give you a way
to charge your new iPhone 7 this is
lightning
these are USB see you'll have to get
another cable to be able to charge your
iPhone with your new MacBook Pro so my
solution for this I bought this I told
you guys to buy this and I'm sure many
of you actually did get it if you're
planning on buying this MacBook Pro or
if you have a MacBook Air so this is a
five and one USB C hub and this is in
the slate gray color it's not exactly
the same color as this macbook so it's
gonna kind of drive me a little bit nuts
and also something and started driving
these super crazy if this little light
is blue and the caps lock ski is green
so then will goes on trigger warning but
for the time being this is what we're
going to be using as you can see it is
two USB 3.0 ports it also has an SD card
slot and micro SD card slot and also one
USB C slot let's open up our little
macbook and as I was talking about the
blue and the green can also tell the
color difference not sure if you can see
that well on camera
the thing that you will notice is how
massive this
touchpad is I was actually in shock when
I first saw because it's it's huge
here's my hand the touchpad is bigger
than the iPhone 7
I wish the Apple pencil would work on
this that would have been so awesome
don't want to try it I'm gonna see just
just a double check and make sure it
doesn't work I tell you what you can't
do stick this in there I'll charge my
pencil while we wait now I'd like to
take you guys through a little bit of
the touch bar features and also see what
it looks like in Final Cut and just take
it for a quick spin so as you can see
here this is our lovely little unlock
screen and if learning me that I can
unlock with touch ID which I already set
up so let's do it
touch unlocked of course the highlight
of this MacBook is the touch bar which
you'll see here
you guys aren't asking me what the touch
bar feels like it feels sort of like the
trackpad but a little bit slicker kind
of feels like your iPhone but a little
less shiny so as you can see here this
is final cuts the touch bar changes
depending upon what app you have open so
this is back to the finder so the finder
opens up with corresponding one assist
but I haven't even tried all these
things out there's a lot of things to
get used to click to final cuts this
will allow me to import footage just by
touching the touch bar let's see if I
can find myself some footage I think I
set myself a couple files it's fast this
is all 4k footage send that in kind of
fast so this looks like it's just a trim
I just trimmed this entire clip using
the touch bar let's see it will turn
this volume down and this is the volume
that's actually adjusting the track on
the clip Fears see that
hey Siri open up pages here's a blank
document as you can see change is
corresponding to whatever it is that
you're doing this basically looks kind
of like your iPhone when you're typing
it brings up the suggestion bar right
here is the emojis which is something
that I am pretty excited about because I
love emojis so right here you can see
this is the entire timeline
in final cut so I'm just scrolling my
finger back and forth and I can see
everything oh this is going to be so
exciting guys I'm going to edit this
video on Final Cut on the new Mac Pro
and I'll let you know how it goes in a
future video so now something that I
like to do and I love doing this when I
get new products is do a comparison of
then and now so this is where we
currently are now I would like to show
you guys my first MacBook ever this is
the MacBook that started it all I made
my first youtube videos on this any of
the first ask I DFS's I actually shot
those with the iSight camera and a
little blue microphone this is in part
what was it called eyesight then it's
called FaceTime camera so there's some
yeah it was called on sight then oh
these are really heavy
and here she is the baby that started it
all oh look at them next to each other
oh honey I mean this thing still had a
CD slot I didn't even have a charger
that would work with this anymore
definitely lost and this has the
removable battery well doesn't look like
it's charged oh wow oh boy look how
little oh boy you're so teeny something
that used to drive me crazy is that the
space bar was not lined up with the
trackpad we've come so far there's a few
missing in between because I usually
will do a pass down computers if I get a
new one I will give it to a family
member or I just like to keep them
because some people collect photographs
some people like to remember memories I
remember my life through which MacBook
or Apple product I had so yeah
so this is the current one that I'm
using this is my baby
we've been through a lot now we're going
to check out this is the first MacBook
Air this is a great computer it was so
slow it also took a small little little
fall you can see there but it still
worked and now something that is the
closest companion to this is the latest
MacBook Air which really is an
incredible device I was still able to
edit 4k footage on this granted it's
very slow but you could still do it same
sort of keyboard and this is a really
beautiful machine it's really really
really nice if you guys aren't doing
anything that's that insane like editing
or anything that's to processor
intensive honestly MacBook Airs
just it's really great it's really great
I know we get upset at Apple for not
doing the things that we think they
should do but man I'll tell you what
it's really beautiful
call me a sheep call me fool I've got
pcs I know that there are computers with
higher specs and in comparison to what
you're paying for a Mac but a lot of
what you're paying for a Mac is the OS
and for it to work and the other
applications that work with it you're
really paying for an experience and
usually for the most part that
experience is so good that it is worth
it and if you're a PC person that's
really fine I get it I still do my live
streams on my PC I play games on my PC
and I do edit almost everything in Final
Cut Pro X so for me this is going to be
the most perfect machine it will be
interesting to see how the editing
process goes on here though and if it is
faster if the touch bar really does help
that much I think right now it's sort of
is a novelty item until you kind of
figure out all of how it works so once
you do that then you're going to be set
last but not least
yeah you know you can't you can't write
on it
Oh guys that doesn't for my MacBook Pro
overview I'm pretty excited to try this
out I'll probably be doing a two days
with MacBook probably a video of
traveling with my back book for the
first time and probably a week with my
back book and then I mean I might as
well do a things that I like about my
MacBook video and then I'll probably do
with things that I don't like about my
MacBook video and then I do problem at
it I should probably just do with things
that I wish my MacBook had and then
maybe I'll do update with my MacBook and
then maybe I'll do sleeping with my
MacBook and maybe I'll even do I don't
know coffee with ice I think it's okay
I'll see you guys later
should I start like buying like a sheep
sheep called me an app should call me
what you want what you really really
want but I like my back oh my sweet
sweet MacBook I just wanted to give you
guys an update because I edited my
entire video the video that you just
watched on this little guy sitting right
here on this couch I've got a this
harddrive hooked up to it it's USB see
holy moly this touch bars it's
incredible
you know we made fun of it we swept
everybody makes their little jokes but
wow it is so good for the smallest
things you guys think shortcut keys are
amazing well let me tell you what touch
bar shortcut keys are even shorter a
small side note as well today when I was
putting my macbook into my backpack
the MacBook fell backwards so I
basically like put the MacBook into my
book bag with my face and hit off of my
nose and it was the most painful thing
ever
I've got like this huge bumps
oh my goodness either way this thing's
amazing I'm so happy I'm so so happy I
love you guys see you later
I'm so nervous it's the Space Gray oh
you guys want to see it here it is it's
in its little case it's little box it's
little